we all regularly drive for the car we
want to get to from point A to point B
usually we like to drive with a constant
speed but what happens if there's a
traffic light well we have to stop
eventually which means we have to brake
and that makes the car decelerate so
there are different parts of motion when
we write a car it can be constant it can
be accelerating they can be decelerating
so let's consider this in a little
graphic we have a little car here and it
drives with constant speed until someone
slams into the brakes and the car will
eventually stop let's add a time line to
this here we're going to put T equals
zero the point in time where the car
stops driving con with a constant speed
is t1 and the point where the car have
come to a complete stop is t2 and the
the problem now asks for what is the
position function what is the distance
at any kind of time here as the car goes
through these two different phases of
motion so ultimately we want to get to X
of T but we can't actually just write
this up we we need to first look at
other information that we have about
this kind of setup and what we have is
information on the acceleration and we
have to consider these two phases
separately so we have here phase one and
phase two and phase one is from zero to
t 1 and phase two is from t1 to t2
and we know when a car is going with a
constant velocity its acceleration is
going to be zero so that keeps life easy
for phase one and then when it breaks
well we know it decelerate so we're
definitely going to have a minus sign
and it breaks in between t and t 1 and
we need to multiply this factor here
with a constant so this is our
acceleration information that the
problem is has given us and we know of
course that if we integrate the
acceleration we're going to get to the
velocity function and if we integrate
that one again we're going to get to our
position function so let's do that first
for Phase one and what is also important
here is that we need to carefully
consider the initial conditions again
what info what additional information is
this problem giving us so initial
conditions they always make life a lot
easier so it's careful to it's important
to carefully look for them and what that
means is we want to know what the
distance is at T equals zero and what
the velocity at time zero is and we know
the distance here is zero and we know
that the the problem starts when the car
is already driving with a constant speed
so that's going to be V naught so let's
then make use of this and start
integrating our acceleration we want to
get to the velocity so V of T minus V of
T equals zero is going to be that
integral and here already we know that V
of T equals zero is V naught so this
already looks pretty nice and now we
have our integral here of a and of
course now T is an integration variable
so we have to give this a prime and
we're integrating from t prime equals
zero
to T prime equals T and when we plug
those in well a is zero in phase one
which means actually our integral is
going to be zero that's handy and from
that we will find that V of T equals
simply V not all good now we need to
integrate this to get to our position
function same thing again X of t minus X
of T equals zero let's quickly check
here what we know about X of T zero well
it's zero from the initial conditions
and now we have to integrate our
velocity function here V not DT again
prime t prime equals zero T prime equals
T these are our boundaries and this is
simply going to be V naught T prime
evaluated from zero to T and we can add
that we can add that in there and it's
just going to be V T so X of T I can
just write it here again X of T equals V
naught T okay good so half of the
question is half of the problem is
solved let's look at the same things for
Phase two so let's consider the initial
conditions for Phase two now and again
now we want to in an analogous way look
at the distance of what what we know
about the distance at T 1 and the
velocity at t1 and about the position we
know from over there that this is V
naught T so our pervious result now
actually becomes the initial condition
for the next step rate because whatever
happens here sets whatever happens
afterwards so that's that's nice and we
know that up to this moment here this
car goes with a velocity of me not